how is it possible that I can be
attacked relentlessly hundreds of times
a day according to Republican
congressman Devin Nunez the abuse he's
endured on Twitter is of a breadth and
scope that no human being should ever
have to bear and suffer in their whole
life he's been called a presidential
fluffer and swamp rent a treasonous
[ __ ] a Putin shill a feckless [ __ ] an
unscrupulous craven backstabbing
charlatan and traitor and voted most
likely to commit treason in high school
now this California lawmaker and Trump
ally is suing Twitter for 250 million
dollars for quote emotional distress and
mental suffering and injury to his
personal and professional reputations
he's also asking the court to force
Twitter to reveal the true identities
behind Twitter accounts Devin Nunez mom
Devin Nunez Cal fired Devin Nunez and
Devin Nunez grapes so on what grounds
can an elected official sue a social
media platform for speech that offends
him Twitter is not merely a website the
lawsuit alleges it is the modern town
square a public forum with a private
owner Nunez says that the lawsuit is
also part of a strategy to fight back
against lies in the press related to the
Russia investigation named in the
quarter of a billion dollar lawsuit
right alongside Devin Nunez his mom and
Devon Nunez his cow is Liz Mayer a
Republican strategist and self-described
libertarian who angered Nunez for among
other things delivering a pair of yellow
New Balances to his congressional office
after he ran out of a committee hearing
on the Russia scandal i sat down with
mayor to talk about the lawsuit and what
it means for free speech on the Internet
Liz thanks for joining us you are named
in as one of the parties in this suit
the other three parties are Twitter the
company and then two anonymous Twitter
accounts one is Devin hoon as his mom
the other one is Devin Nunez is cow yes
how does it feel to be named as a party
in a lawsuit alongside a fake cow well I
first of all let me say that I'm I'm a
little jealous of the cow I have to be
honest apparently the cows Twitter
followers have now surpassed the number
of Twitter followers that Devin Nunez
has mine personally have not so I would
of course appeal to all of your viewers
and
of your readers to please follow me so
that I can feel better about my standing
on social media relative to the cow that
isn't really a cow because this is just
terribly upsetting for me that I'm not
as popular as they fake farmyard animal
so this is on the one hand incredibly
absurd and it's also kind of serious
it's it's very serious
I I joke about the cow portion of it but
this is very serious because at the end
of the day what this lawsuit
fundamentally is about is about free
speech and First Amendment rights in
this country which I believe are
foundational to the Republic that we
have at the end of the day the reason
that we have the First Amendment is
because the framers firmly believed in
the right of American citizens to
criticize their government and in this
case what we actually have is a sitting
member of the US government a sitting
member of the US House of
Representatives who is using litigation
as a cudgel to silence and stifle free
speech of an American citizen who he
happens to find bothersome
and not just to stifle free speech but
to stop you from mocking him and that
seems to be a big part of this this
actually talks about all the mean things
that were said about Devin Nunez on
Twitter some of them by you others by
these anonymous accounts and it really
seems like an attempt to prohibit online
mocking I feel like fundamentally what
we have with this lawsuit is ample
evidence of the fact that representative
Nunez is probably in flagrant violation
of the oath that he took as a member of
Congress all of them take an oath to
support and defend the Constitution the
Constitution is an entire document you
cannot pick and choose it is not a
cafeteria document right if you support
and pretend the Constitution you are
also supporting and defending and taking
an oath to support and defend the First
Amendment and the Bill of Rights and the
reality is that the First Amendment
protects my right to free speech and it
protects his right to free speech and it
protects Donald Trump's right to free
speech and it protects your right to
free speech it protects the right of to
suppress speech of every single person
who's going to watch that interview and
this is absolutely fundamental to our
democracy in our republic and it's
really concerning to me as an American
citizen that he's taken this oath to
support and defend the US Constitution
and yet he clear
does not believe in an expansive view of
the First Amendment that I think the
framers very clearly did otherwise they
wouldn't have written it to support
pamphleteers and to protect pamphleteers
who were criticizing their government so
this is not just about Devin Nunez this
is also it seems to me about Donald
Trump and the suit notes that you were
the sponsor of the make America awesome
pact is a super PAC designed to mock the
president during his campaign for
president for the presidency in 2015
2016 Devin Nunez is somebody who is a
staunch supporter of Donald Trump do you
think that this is an attack not just on
speech rights but on the right of
citizens to organize around political
causes in the way that the make America
awesome pact it I can't speak to what
Devin Nunez does motivations are I don't
know what goes on in Devin Nunez his
head I think it would be interesting to
find out of course but what I will say
about this is you know first of all what
I did in 2016 just to clarify that in
the context of the Republican primary
Donald Trump was not who I wanted the
Republican Party of which I am a member
and I've been a member for much longer
than he has it's not who I wanted to
nominate and there was a lot of
information that we dug up about Donald
Trump had moved out there because we
believed that Republican voters had a
right to know about the candidates that
were running in the primary and make an
informed decision and again that is an
exercise of free speech what I think is
really interesting about this lawsuit
though is that given the Devin Nunez
clearly has a very different view of the
applicable law here including the First
Amendment I think that the the sort of
precedent that he could potentially set
here you know I think I'm on the same
side as Donald Trump here we've had a
lot of people criticizing Donald Trump
on Twitter recently for his tweets I
firmly stand with the president in terms
of exerting his rights to free speech I
disagree with him on some policy matters
on others I strongly agree with him you
know I take issue with some of his
ethics and his personal behavior there
are some phraseology that I would not
personally use because it's just not my
style or I think it's particularly rude
or inoffensive but at the end of the day
we have a First Amendment and that First
Amendment applies to Donald Trump just
as much as it applies to me just
as much as it applies to you just as
much as it applies to representative
Nunez and what's really key here is that
representative Nunez has taken an oath
of office to defend that first amendment
and I don't think that he's defending my
right of speech free speech or defending
Donald Trump's right of free speech and
I think that's a problem as an American
citizen and a libertarian Republican so
let's talk a little bit more generally
about the free speech issue then it
strikes me as somewhat ironic that on
the one hand Nunez is saying well my
right to free speech is being suppressed
and he is saying this in a lawsuit that
is attempting to suppress your right to
free speech how do you square those two
things what's going on here well I think
again you would have to ask him to come
on and actually square that circle and
explain to you what is going on here
from my perspective you know as a civil
libertarian and a libertarian Republican
I personally believe in all of the Bill
of Rights and all of our Constitution
and interpreting liberties very broadly
because I think that is fundamental to a
free society you know I'm a British
citizen as well as an American citizen
and one of the reasons I love my other
country but one of the reasons that I
choose to live live here is because we
have a more expansive and established
system of liberties and Freedoms and as
a libertarian I hold my liberty and
freedom
absolutely dearly as I believe the
majority of other Americans do and so
from my perspective it's really
important that we do defend free speech
even if it's speech that we disagree
with her we find personally hurtful or
we find rude I think it's absolutely
essential that we defend that because I
simply don't believe that America is
what it was designed to be if we do not
have that defense in place and if people
do not subscribe to that fundamental
principle and apparently representative
Nunez and I have very different views
about the right to free speech and about
the First Amendment but I certainly
would hope that most Americans would
have the same you if it that I do
because I believe it is one of the
things that has led to us being the
greatest country on earth the greatest
force for freedom and liberty on earth
and a country that we should all be
incredibly proud to be citizens of
you're describing this as an attack not
only on your
speech but on the speech rights of every
citizen including President Trump yes I
do I do believe that president Trump's
rights of free speech are under siege
for many quarters and that's something
that I have a real problem with I'm not
necessarily a fan of the president he
was not my preferred choice of nominee
in 2016 I think that's been abundantly
clear I have also said that when it
comes to the November 20 2011 you know I
want to be clear about that
but setting aside any of those political
calculations that anybody may make the
fact of the matter is whether you like
Donald Trump or you don't like Donald
Trump we have a first amendment in this
country and it applies to him just as
much as it applies to anybody else and
that's something that I think really is
important for everybody to understand
free speech rights in enlarge are under
siege from many many quarters and you
know my First Amendment rights are
obviously extremely important for me to
defend in this context but I think it's
really important especially for people
who are going to be watching this
interview who I'm pretty sure agree with
me about the importance of construing
civil liberties broadly and maintaining
as much freedom and liberty as is
humanly possible within our society it's
really important that all of those
people step up and I'll just add here
because I'm sort of duty-bound to do so
that if people want to support my legal
defense in this matter they can go to
swamp accountability project calm and
they can donate there the reality of the
situation is that we are probably going
to incur some look at some legal costs I
don't know how much in the context of
this litigation but if people believe in
free speech and they want to defend the
First Amendment and the right to free
speech that is one way that they can
help do so in addition to their own
behavior and their own attitudes on a
day to day basis those are the
consequences for you specifically but
draw this out a little bit if this suit
were to succeed this is a quarter of a
billion dollar lawsuit against you
Twitter and these fake accounts if this
suit were to succeed what are the stakes
what would happen what would be the
upshot of a suit like this being
successful well again I think you
probably need to bring somebody who's
actually a litigator and a First
Amendment and a constitutional or public
law litigator on to your program to
actually discuss that in specific I am
English qualified solicitor I am NOT a
US qualified lawyer nor do I think it's
a good idea to get into talking about
the merits or demerits of this
particular lawsuit but what I will say
is as an American citizen I think again
when we start constraining civil
liberties that is really really a risk
to the fundamental nature of our
republic and people need to ask
themselves on a daily basis and this is
true regardless of what period of time
we're in and who's in office and who's
in power and who's in the majority and
who's in the minority and what's going
on in courts people need to ask
themselves what kind of society do they
want to live in do they want to live in
a free society which is what America has
traditionally been where we have those
expansive liberties unlike many other
countries or do we want to constrain
that and from my perspective we do not
want to constrain that and I think that
if we do start doing that whether we're
talking about the First Amendment or
many other amendments for that matter I
think that we're headed towards an
America that is not what the framers
intended it is not reflective of our
traditional cultural values it is not
reflective of most Americans
philosophies and ideals and I think
frankly it would be very problematic for
the country final question do you know
if Devin Nunez actually has a cow ooh
I don't offhand you would have to google
around about this and maybe take a look
at something like his financial
disclosure forms I do know that he is
invested in a winery dad I do know Liz
thanks so much for talking with me today
thank you so much for having me